[Música]
o celular aqui pra começar a pensar um
pouquinho fora da caixa né
é a gente não está acostumado a ver as
pessoas sempre apresentando da mesma
forma usando a tecnologia a favor mas a
favor sempre da mesma forma então queria
inovar já trazendo aqui minhas anotações
no celular e estimular que vocês pensem
fora da caixa eu me formei analista de
sistemas mas eu sou um cara de educação
então tô aqui pra falar de educação com
vocês né
antes de tudo queria 351 dias da atenção
de vocês aí o processamento do cérebro
de vocês aí eu queria saber se a
tecnologia mudou a vida de vocês nos
últimos dois anos né
a minha mudou acho que de seis meses pra
casa teve mudança e diretamente a
tecnologia está aí é e todos os lugares
e eu por exemplo trouxe que o meu
celular por todas as minhas anotações
para provocar a forma em que a gente
assistir palestras né a forma em que os
palestrantes hoje outras pessoas que
querem se comunicar com muitas pessoas
acabam usando é sempre pt de algumas
décadas atrás e é isso aqui na verdade é
só pra motivar vocês a pensar fora da
caixa que é o nosso intuito aqui hoje
e aí é vendo essa modificação aí né
sofrendo essa modificação com a
tecnologia eu gosto de pensar que a
tecnologia está para o nosso bem é a
gente está evoluindo e com a sociedade e
é com o apoio dessa tecnologia
a gente hoje usa a tecnologia para tudo
usa tecnologia desde a medicina até a
educação em si
às vezes a educação se usa muito bem mas
enfim a gente tá melhorando isso é mas a
gente passa por tudo transporte s
refletor aqui e ele tem tecnologia que a
gente vê quando falta luz é um problema
mas é uma pouca coisa que a gente tá tá
melhorando e também gente olha aí
foi melhorar oportunidade pra todo mundo
aí e aí uma coisa é interessante de ver
é que nos últimos dois anos a gente
produziu 98% da produção digital
significa que a tecnologia está aí ó
findo é contudo e principalmente essa
tecnologia foi absorvida está sendo essa
produção de coca sendo em grande parte
dessa nova geração uma geração que é já
nasceu de novo assim na tecnologia é meu
filho por exemplo tem dois nomes ele ea
gente monitorava esposa agente
monitorava ele no berço usando uma
câmera onde é o do trabalho de qualquer
outro lugar podia é acompanhar se estava
dormindo se tivesse virado face virou a
câmera me avisar então ou seja já tinha
um robozinho é uma tecnologia me
apoiando isso aí
ou seja a tecnologia já estava no meu
dia a dia há dois anos atrás aí e aí é
essa técnica essa tecnologia já está no
dia a dia dessa nova geração essa nova
geração usa muito bem isso nessa época
gerou muito bem disso aí
mas por outro lado a gente vê a eu tenho
34 anos hoje é meu filho tem dois anos
eu adoro dirigir quando tirei minha
carteira no dia que eu fiz 18 anos eu
fui lá no de tron e peguei a minha
habilitação e já fiquei superfeliz apple
possa dirigir tal mas o que significa
isso para o meu filho agora tem dois
anos e muito provavelmente não vai
dirigir um carro vai querer pensar nisso
porque aquelas autônomos né
outras formas de economia pra
transformar o translado né a o
direcionamento das pessoas dentro de uma
de uma cidade é a não necessariamente
diretamente em transporte público mas né
esse dinamização que a tecnologia traz
pra gente mas eu fico meio né com um pé
atrás mas tudo bem disse pra ele é não
dirigir é uma coisa legal se sabe
conviver com isso e aí a gente voltar um
pouco mais atrás cerca disso a 60 70
anos atrás a agricultura ainda é muito
forte aqui no país
logo depois a gente veio é a com
revolução industrial gente que o
professor mostrou agora as datas
certinhas e hoje a gente está
vivenciando essa revolução da tecnologia
o legal a gente vê aí três gerações para
trás a gente já mudou questom desde
educação até é a forma de dar na
profissão o meu avô o meu bisavô muito
provavelmente eles nasceram filho da
profissão deles
então se eles foram filhos de padeiro
provavelmente filho padeiros ele seriam
essas forem filhos de pedreiro filho de
qualquer outra de pessoas com profissões
já consolidadas filhos méxico que seja
comprovadamente médico seria meu pai já
estudou para escolher uma opção ali uma
evolução legal da sociedade
mas aí ele escolheu essa profissão e fez
a profissão na vida toda é muito
provavelmente mudar de profissão na
geração passada uma coisa muito complexa
hoje não hoje eu sou como falei só
analista de sistemas
hoje eu sou professor é eu já mudei de
profissão irão taxas bem grande e é três
ou quatro vezes na minha vida eu eu
costumo dizer que a gente muda ou melhor
a gente tem que mudar de profissão
a cada cinco anos o museu não deu uma
palestra muito legal também pede falando
que é a esteira rolante da vida está
vindo muito rápido e se a gente não
mudar se a gente não evoluísse a gente
não dá saltos nessa
nessa esteira rolante a gente acaba
ficando pra trás e essa transformação a
cada cinco anos pra mim é a visão de
mudar de esteira hoje dá um salto lá na
frente mas aí por outro lado a gente
pensa assim como tem que mudar cada
cinco anos
então minha profissão
mudar a cada cinco anos não
necessariamente a verdade o que depende
é dessa mudança acontecer é você você
tem que fazer a mudança acontecer seja a
mudança no ambiente em que você está
ou seja a mudança interna é a gente hoje
via tecnologia muito próxima à bolsa de
valores hoje quando a gente vê um filme
de ficção uma propaganda ou o próprio
jornal comentando alguma coisa da bolsa
de valores a gente não vê mais aquela
aquela confusão aquele caos das pessoas
no telefone por um lado pro outro gritam
a gente não vê mais isso a gente só tem
um gráfico que significa isso é fácil
tecnologia a tecnologia hoje toma conta
da de 90 por cento da bolsa de valores
ou seja cada dez transações só um efeito
humano
as outras novas são feitas por roubo
então tem uma galera que faz importar
tecnologia está vindo aí os robôs vão
dominar a galera
acorda fogo já dominaram a nossa nossa
economia já está na mão deles
então o que a gente fazia como é que eu
penso em educação que a gente tem que
fazer a gente tem que se preparar para
usar essa tecnologia a nosso favor
essa aqui a falar que eu queria deixar
para vocês aqui hoje
a gente estudou é aprende programação eu
sou professor de programação e aprende
programação mas aprendi pra que só para
escrever o script não a gente tem que
aprender a usar a tecnologia a nossa rua
a gente tem hoje já têm inteligência
artificial é mais do que conversando com
humanos como a gente viu nas sessões
anteriores
a gente já tem inteligência artificial
criando e pensando objetos então que é
isso a gente já tem um é protótipo de
chassis de carros que são muito mais
seguros que foram construídos elaborados
por inteligência artificial eo pior
ainda um humano não consegue produzir
fisicamente precisa de uma impressora 3d
deu um recurso maquinário para conseguir
produzir esse chassi de carro
isso é uma coisa bem absurdo
essa trazer para a nossa realidade hoje
a gente vai no banheiro do papel
higiênico naquele mesmo formato foi
criado sei lá quantos sei lá milhões de
anos até falar quanto tempo será que não
vai vir uma inteligência artificial e
pensar num papel higiênico no formato
novo revolucionário que vai economizar
papel que vale o melhor é essas coisas
todas é isso pra muita gente assusta
pra mim me deixa muito satisfeito muito
feliz
a partir do momento em que a gente
começa a usar essa tecnologia a nosso
favor que a gente consegue aprender isso
aí é um reflexo disso é a no final do
ano passado uma aluna minha se formou
ela fez uma entrevista numa empresa
super top de desenvolvimento no rio e
ela se tornou escravo mas ter alguém que
conhece essa profissão ainda que você
entende 5% a lei profissões novas
profissões antigas são terminadas dando
assim som é diminuída sair quantidade de
seres humanos atacando e sim mas outras
são triadas webdesign design com essa é
a mas tem uma série de outras profissões
que estão sendo criadas por exemplo tô
de ensino à distância é todo mundo que
pode ser um tutor de ensino à distância
é é uma profissão que foi criada e os
últimos anos então ela ensina também não
teve andré beleza
então a gente tem que tentar usar essa
tecnologia a nosso favor para tentar
finalizar aqui uma idéia é voltar lá
para a educação ea hoje a gente vivencia
uma educação muito complexa né
hoje a gente ainda usando métodos de
instalar 40 50 anos atrás para ensinar
hoje uma geração que precisa aprender
para o futuro né essa geração não
precisa aprender para vivenciar o
passado antes
dei preferência ao futuro e como é que a
gente faz isso é será que é ainda
fazendo prova será que ainda fazendo
prova sem a ajuda da tecnologia
eu tô aqui com o meu celular me apoiando
para lembrar o meu discurso que é porque
o aluno não pode ter ali uma ferramenta
apoiando ele para lembrar o discurso
dele se a todo momento a gente não sai
de casa sem alguma tecnologia e hoje
essa madrugada deixei aqui meu celular
carregando isso o tirei do do carregador
no momento que eu fui sair de carro para
ter uma segurança de que a tecnologia
vai me acompanhar durante todo o meu
percurso durante o dia então porque as
pessoas já não podem aprender a usar
isso e usar isso no dia a dia como parar
de criminalizar a tecnologia em todos os
ambientes todo o ambiente a tecnologia
tem que está deve estar
vamos nos tornar humanos mais
capacitados porque a tecnologia está
junto com a gente porque eu não posso
usar um smartphone ou ate q me avisa seu
poder uma taquicardia com o professor
falou mais cedo posse usávamos a a gente
não pode ficar escravo disso mas a gente
pode sim se tornar humanos mais
capacitados e melhores usando tecnologia
então pra isso a gente tem que levar
isso para a sala de aula
se a gente não levar para as salas de
aula se os nossos alunos hoje nessas
nossos estudantes hoje não aprenderem a
usar a tecnologia a favor deles
a gente vai ter só mais uma geração
daqui a 10 15 anos que vai continuar não
sabemos a um negócio que está dominando
o planeta
e aí é volta aquela preocupação nem eu é
a sua neta sistemas professor é dó de
programação e aí muitas pessoas me
pergunta por antônia que você faz que
você ensina como é que a sua aula né
gosto de falar de aula meus alunos me
pergunta o professor vai ter lógica
aulas e vamos cobrar aula enfim parece
e aí o que eu costumo falar que na
verdade
eu acho que todo mundo tem que fazer que
é ensinar e aprender a usar a tecnologia
a nosso favor então eu vou deixar aqui é
um pedido e se educação dever de todos
vou pedir ajuda de todos vocês pra
ensinarem as pessoas próximas a vocês em
qualquer circunstância a usar a
tecnologia a seu favor
obrigado galera
[Música]